hi there Steve here and today I want to
talk about whether everyone can learn a
language or why some people can't learn
languages and so forth and the reason
I'm doing that is because there was a
comment on my blog
the linguist on language and you should
maybe I'll leave a link to my blog so
you can go visit but someone wrote in
and said you'll notice by the way that I
have different glasses on every day and
that's because I had this eye operation
lens replacement so now I only need
reading glasses so I buy three or four
pairs of inexpensive glasses and leave
them lying around so that wherever I am
I don't have to Oh looking for my
glasses at any rate Robert writes he
says I must disagree that everyone is
capable of learning another language
this is blankly false it's like saying
that anyone can learn to sing from years
of language learning and teaching it is
clear that some people have no ear for
language they cannot discriminate toes
emulate correct pronunciation can't
remember even the most most basic
vocabulary words much less complex
grammatical structures or constructions
blah blah blah I realized that for
marketing purposes companies emphasize
the ease of language learning at any age
it simply isn't true homes across
America are littered with rosetta stone
that proved overwhelming and blah blah
blah okay so where do I come on that I
completely disagree with Robert first of
all language learning is not like
singing everyone can sing people don't
sing equally well everyone can learn
languages people don't all speak equally
well so did that except it's similar but
the reason I say everyone can learn is
if you go to certain countries like
Sweden just about everybody speaks
English in Singapore I have yet to meet
a person from Singapore that doesn't
speak at least one dialect to Chinese
and English and possibly Malay whatever
it's called bahasa
um and there's probably other examples
of that so it's not that some people can
learn and other people can't learn it's
that some people either choose not to
learn or have an attitude that
encourages them to learn but there's
nothing in essence within us that
prevents us from learning and that
reminded me of another person who had a
similar comment and whom I quoted in my
book and that's John Milton the English
poet and he said we Englishmen being far
northerly do not open our mouths in the
cold air wide enough to grace a southern
tongue so as far as he was concerned
English people couldn't learn French or
Spanish I guess or Italian again
absolute nonsense some wonderful
polyglots that I know you know speak
lots of different languages and open
their mouths quite widely in fact in
thinking of that quote from Milton which
I used in my book I went and grabbed a
copy of my book in other words I don't
want to find this quote and in rereading
my book I really believe that I normally
I don't plug my book but I wrote this
book I guess over 10 years ago there's
nothing in there that I have that I
don't still believe and I'm actually
amazed at how a lot of the things that I
have subsequently learned by reading
crash and by following watching people
learn and so forth and being active here
on the internet it's all in the book I
really recommend those of you who are
interested should get a copy of the book
it's available on Amazon the linguist a
personal guide to language learning
however just for the fun of it the first
ten people who send me an email
requesting the book I will send them the
book free of charge you can ask for the
e-book or you can ask for the book paper
copy and I will send it to you that's my
gift for today my Christmas gift you
will I'm Steve at the linguist calm
alright so those who are interested send
me an email
and tell me whether you want the e-book
or the printed version now getting back
to this business of anyone can learn and
I firmly believe that it's a matter of
at its essence attitude spending the
time believing you can do it wanting to
do it and finding things of interest to
learn from so in my own case now having
finished my three months of Korean and
having achieved and this was my second
90 day attack on Korean on each occasion
I've improved but I I have to admit I'm
finding Korean difficult so I decided
that for the next three months I'm gonna
concentrate on four Slavic languages and
part of my reason for doing this
experiment is that you know I'm a firm
believer in what I think was Manfred
Spitzer the German neuroscientist said
and that is that the brain needs
repetition and yet it needs novelty and
and this ties into the research that
Robert Bjork of UCLA has done about how
we can't block learn things we need to
learn it and leave it learn it and leave
it interleaving is called very things
around so I am spending my learning time
today or these days for the next three
months listening to and reading in
Russian polish Czech and Ukrainian so
having decided to do that I went looking
for material so I signed up to audio
tech ax dot cz this cut which is a an
audio book site for Czech and I
discovered that they offer not only
audio books but also audio versions of
Czech magazines that led me to the
magazine site so I am now I now get the
audio versions of these magazines
because I got the app for my iPhone I
get them on my iPhone and the texts I
import into link then I discovered that
and I think someone here at on
a YouTube channel here told me there's
an audio technica PL for Polish so I
went there and there I was able to do
the same
get the app on my phone and then I said
geez that's why I also subscribe to a
magazine car door jet d'eau jet ski I
think it's pronounced anyway so I got
that then I see that V board saw which
is a leading newspaper in Poland also
offers both content
it offers content I can remember where
they got audio there no maybe not but I
subscribed to them and I got a free
audio book from it then someone who
follows my channel here who lives in
Russia named but we had a he said you
know I can help you with the rush let's
have a chat so we chatted what was his
name boy nice fellow we spoke on the
he'll remind me I can look it up and he
said you should read this history book
by a Coulomb Boris a Coonan the history
of the Russian government historia de
sky gas Siddhartha so I looked for that
on the internet and I found it at a site
a fabulous site called lit res like
litres if you want Li TR es which is
full of both text and audio that you can
buy and they also have an app so I now
have the lead rest app on my iPhone and
so I've got the audio of this book on my
iPhone and the actual text of the book I
bought and downloaded and I study in
link so and of course for Ukrainian I
haven't been as lucky I have some
material that I found for Ukrainian and
I have a magazine I have a book Zelezny
octi Ukrainian historian basically a
series of lectures on myths of Ukrainian
history so I'm reading that so all I'm
saying is we learn best from content of
interest which is something that I said
10 years ago we learned best when we're
not trying to learn the language try to
push the language into our brain we
learn best when we're using the language
to explore something else but that
something else has to be there there
has to be something that you're
interested in learning so in the case of
the Swedish children who watch American
cartoons and programs and learn their
English that way because they're they're
not doing that because they want to
learn English they're doing that because
they're interested in the program and
I'm interested in these various history
things that I'm accessing now in for
Slavic languages so we get back to this
issue of can people learn if they're not
interested if they're not interested in
anything other than trying to force the
language into their brains yeah they're
gonna have trouble but I think anyone
who has an interest in something in the
language that they will therefore learn
the language in order to get at the
thing that they're interested in and
that cannot be just I need the language
for my job that's not a strong enough
motivation I need the language because I
want to learn about this through the
language a person who has that
motivation it doesn't matter who he or
she is they will learn the language so
again it's not a matter of the gene for
language learning and ear for language
learning I mean the Japanese are great
singers if you go to a karaoke bar in
Japan they're the best singers but
they're not necessarily the best
language marriage I'm a lousy singer I'm
actually quite a successful language
learner so it's all about attitude
and your time you spend on the task with
the language your interest in it and so
Robert I completely disagree with you
and that's my video for today bye for
now